that's bark in a good mood which he very
often is and don't think he was some
distant academic he got into a sword
fight with a bassoonist cuz he he told
the bassoonist he sounded like a nanny
goat and he got put in prison for other
things he was and he also got into
trouble for um making music with a young
lady in the organ
Loft um he was he was a ladb he was full
of fire and temperament and apparently
when he conducted they said was like he
had rhythm in every part of his
body um but of course there was another
side besides the joy besides the fire
and the excitement there's also this
incredible profundity and I thought I
would play
you without
repeats um
probably no I think we I think I might
have time for the repeats the sarahan
from the fifth Suite now this is for me
the the whole Suite is is the passion
story for cello and for me this is the
moment of the crucifixion where Christ
is abandoned on the cross but it doesn't
matter whether you think that or not
it's such a portrait of loneliness I
mean it's like it's not really like but
maybe one of the highest high points of
music for me is is IAD in the St Matthew
passion where
Simon Peter realizes that the has
crowed three times and he has denied
Christ and the ARA that follows just
sums up everything that we feel in
moments you know when we feel remorse
when we feel
grief um everything and this too this
saraban for me sums up
loneliness and anguish but it's not
depressing it's never depressing because
there's a a gain a Radiance to it that
it's it sublimates suffering through
[Music]
Beauty
m
[Music]